and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised hello everyone and a very warm
welcome to our sunset Safari driver
today all the way from Juma Game Reserve
in South Africa and my name is David and
with me tree on the camera AC VM and you
might wonder what I have been doing
there I've been trying to get some
flowers I don't know that anybody has
heard of flowers that grow underground
and what has happened here is the season
is not try to get any flowers and all
the flowers I wanted to get what to send
to all of you nights mothers wherever
you are in the world and wish you a very
happy Mother's Day ray VM to VM agrees
with me to all of you happy Mother's Day
and so sorry I couldn't get any flowers
in whoo-ha it's not the right season for
flowers I tried to dig some flowers down
there I did not get any my apologies for
us but please accept our very nice
wishes for the happy Mother's Day today
right I'm not alone today out on safari
I'm joined by my other brother by the
name of James we'll be driving like me
and I'm also joined by ruff caste we'll
be doing a bit of walking remember this
is a very interactive Safari Drive where
we need you to engage us with your
questions and comments
it's nice temperature today 26 degrees
in about 79 degrees Fahrenheit so not
bad to find out who could be out there
for us I got a mission today
King Ghana was spotted early this
morning by one gal by the name of Taylor
and I'm trying to see whether we're
going to find him
where she left her one more time welcome
and be with us for the many part of the
drive
right so we got a mission we got a
mission and see if we're going to find
ting Ghana who have come to follow in
love with and one of the original one
would like to say hello to you and find
out how his face looks like today after
he did a bit of this morning there's a
he gave Gracie's Barbara up there Craig
I could not say the name of the bird to
Craig Paul Craig because of course a
David was talking about me and worms I
didn't really understand him till I
remember this morning hello everybody
good afternoon and welcome to the sunday
sunset Safari there goes the Krista's
poppet you saw it flying away my name is
James Henry and of course we have got
Batman on camera today
well done betters that was his thumb
whizzing past like a bat swing please do
talk to us using the hashtag spy live on
Twitter otherwise a chat stream on
YouTube we'd love to have any questions
or comments that you might have on this
rather subdued Sunday
I'd say subdued Sunday on account of the
fact that I have yet to find anything
more than an Impala
well we found wildebeest this morning as
well but hopefully we're going to have
something with fur and claws today I
hope that would be marvelous
it's a lovely afternoon it's warmish 26
degrees Celsius or so 79 Fahrenheit I'm
told I think it's going to cool down cut
substantially as we go towards the
winter in the winter no it will get
cooler towards the winter I meant the
evening that we won't be driving
continuously until the winter we will be
going home for supper before that time
good I'm sorry we missed that crested
bothered because it was quite possibly
the most colorful thing that we'll see
okay now look here I am tired of talking
about my hat
Ghost Rider I know my hat looks tattered
okay I know it does look at it it looks
tattered I gave my new hat to Ralph
that's why Ralph has a new hat I bought
a new hat for myself and Ralph is now
wearing it that is why my hat is
tattered and I have ordered another one
and I unfortunately ordered a book with
the other one in the post and the book
they didn't get until now which means
it's only going to be delivered in two
weeks if it is offending you so
appalling me then I should buy another
one then won't fit me and I look silly
thank you thank you Luke Luke says he
thinks it's got character
those driving you are correct though I
mean in in all fairness I must admit
that it's a scrappy looking hat and it
does need to be replaced I mean it it is
it is a little tired thank you
you say my hat is perfect just like me
at least you don't have to look at that
all the time my bald head there was a
time when I started this job that I was
unable to take my hat off in front of
the camera so ashamed was I of my male
pattern baldness but you have all been
so nice to me over the years that I now
know that you will accept me for who I
am just like my mother does and I need
to say that of course because today it
seems like it seems like a slightly
ridiculous opening segment but there it
is
now let us hope for something in these
hearings a thunder of water pigs yes I
think that this is a very good topic of
discussion while we look towards that's
crowned left wing over there and a
hornbill good grief
two species and even some starlings over
here ting gana sawing this morning I was
extremely excited when I heard that in
fact I got slight two goose bumps when I
heard that the old fellow was back
telling everybody that he was feeling
much better and he had been and that
Hawk Murray had better watch it out that
is the crowned Lapwing in case you were
wondering and there we have a red built
horn battle marvelous well we'll keep
looking around here northwestern corner
I'm not sure where else we're gonna go
probably the far east as well maybe down
to Chitra depending on what David finds
on the subject of David let's go and see
if he's found his lipids that he's in
love with
yes I got a mission today and a very big
mission because having our tailor
sported a spotted chingada this morning
that makes my life easier and I got a
feeling in my heart we'll have to have
been seeing here since i got this car
ting Ghana in a way has touched my heart
I mean his walking style his size the
broad hair that he got the dual up you
know that she has I mean all these
features makes me think is pretty
special
coolerado and above all I love the name
I could be wrong but I think if I
remember very well I was taught in Ghana
means shy I feel that's a local language
and I'm instinct and it's being shy and
to me he looks very bolder
she looks very bold a few times where my
eyes came in contact with he's on want
one he looks at me and I give him an eye
and as I've been saying the talking of
loppers in Kenya is very different from
here every time he would look at me my
eyes would slowly go away like that as
much as every camera operator after me
David relax nothing out of the ordinary
nothing is going to happen so let me see
how my body language will be today how
far my eyes will track deviate from his
gorgeous eyes and I'll give you my own
personal feeling by the end of my
visiting with Singhania it's not very
far from where we are VM let me know
where to turn from
we should go to the right so we'll turn
to the right and from this point go
upwards and go to hajikko the Muromachi
river we just shouldn't how much means
by eating waters right yeah so it's
Church I was such right from where we
are do you think it's up there okay so
we're gonna go in from here okay just to
make sure o goes well and that gives my
car more talk and seating garnet in
Ghana here David comes we need to avoid
some of these stones here by the tree
some are huge and they're like nails and
they could easily give you a flat tire
you don't want to change your tire when
you're so close to big boy like tingling
why told you asking whether the rain is
expected here for the next two days this
time of a year and we're talking the
same subject earlier with VM and he told
me he doesn't see any rain coming here
the next few weeks what do you record
them rains what time do you expect
Wow VM tells me those some rains this
time around last year so it could happen
but I can tell you if you want you know
to talk about rains you go to Kenya you
see what rains are there so yeah VM
tells me it might it's my note we just
cross fingers and sometimes the weather
in Africa has been very erotic the last
couple of years so the time we expect
rain it doesn't come and the time we
don't expect rain we get flooding and
like what's happening in Kenya now is
something we have not seen in very many
years so this is what in Ghana was
spotted this morning by Taylor we slowly
want to keep our eyes going hundred and
eighty degrees the left to right and
find out whether he could be hiding and
waiting for me to reintroduce myself
again all the way from Kenya and you
never know rough caste would like to say
hello to all of you the meantime
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the afternoon bushwalk we're
coming to you live on foot from the Juma
concession of the greater Kruger
National Park of South Africa
my name is Alf Kirsten and on the camera
we've got Davi Davi how's it Davi now
please don't forget to join us on the
hashtag Safari live on Twitter and on
the YouTube live chat join us on this
interactive Bush walk now the idea this
afternoon I've actually taken a vehicle
and driven out and then we walking from
there because um I wanted to get a
little bit away from camp and just
access a couple of different areas that
I haven't walked before and the idea has
been to come to an area where I've seen
quite a bit of lipid activity I've also
seen quite a bit of high in activity in
a similar area too so we've come just to
the east of twin dams and I'm thinking
this might be the perfect area for us to
possibly go through some of these blocks
maybe catch up with them some fresh
tracks of tandy and slalom bah that's a
possibility
and also maybe get some clues in on
whether there's any hyena dins around
yeah on this side now you can see a bit
of the the terrain it's almost like you
get these watersheds areas because we
got up quite a bit and and you know sort
of to our waste from here leading all
the way down to twin dams and their low
water sort of drainage system but as we
go up now it's heading to the watershed
area and all this part would probably be
heading down towards that particular
drainage system but on the sides here
we've got a lot of marilla's and perfect
area for lipids and I know that there's
also a lot of termite mounds around yeah
so both lipid and hyena potentially
excellent area for them so we'll be
looking up for that and as I say just
coming to a new area for me on foot away
from the road we can access the block
and see what has been moving through on
this game pause etc
so I've just seen one of the little
Franklin's jumping out in front of us
you know we do call him the heart attack
bird especially out on foot and speaking
of birds
it seems James also has one to show you
are we lying
are we live we didn't hear that we were
going to go live sorry about that
everybody we were sitting here with some
magpie Fricks and they have now
absconded unfortunately and if I go back
towards where they've gone I think we'll
lose signal almost immediately we're on
the northern boundary so let me continue
forward all there's a Swain since
Franklin my let me do that one swing
since purple can you see it there it's
going behind that gory bush just see
some movement there with its red face
there no let me move forward
there it is
see you there Craig and the magpie
Shrike know what I was trying to do
before we went live by mistake was look
these things up in my in my app so that
I might tell you something I have never
told you before about them and they're
probably one of the less common ones
that we have here and under we will do
our best while we look at the other
small things to find you a dwarf Mongols
say as you can see this chaps eating
seeds apparently they also eat tubers
berries insects in the summer most birds
despite what their beaks might tell you
will eat insects in the summertime when
they can full of fat and nutrition and
protein and seldom in flocks as far as
I'm aware yes usually in pairs or small
family parties bold and conspicuous is
they are that's quite exciting quite
interesting is that they drink twice a
day they're doing morning and evening if
they can and that's quite interesting so
I suppose you wouldn't find them in very
busy areas but you do find lots of other
Franklin's in very dry desert areas but
obviously not the Swanson's
good Unger you seem to be belching or
rather disturbing amount of gas into the
air I mean the car it's not Craig why
hello James no I'm afraid I haven't and
we do have our in sort of Inside Man at
Chitra Chitra that's Dylan Leo Smith
Bryn's brother and Dylan will keep us
posted on boo Chava and her cub I think
you'll probably find that there in the
northern parts of Mala Mala at the
moment which borders on I think it's
what is the one below there is it an
it's something like that there's
basically there's one very slim sliver
of land between children children Mala
Mala and I think you'll find that she's
just coming on to children every so
often and then spending her time
further south of that area which i think
is quite interesting I find that quite
strange because I don't know what other
females there are in that area but for
the fact that Tandon used to spend time
most of her time in the Chadwick area
which now seems to be almost devoid
female lipids wonderful sighting of the
virtuals
Starling common as you like but seldom
do we get a great sighting of them in
good light like this nor do we get them
singing solos this one is giving you
wonderful aria oh and a little Jew tunas
dump and tastic hmm sharpening the beak
that's pictures made infinitely less
attractive by that thing that's now
dripping down in a string yes I I'm
suddenly not that fond of my virtual
Starling sighting the voice is
spectacular
Wow it was very nice
alrighty we'll continue along a northern
boundary David is something else
interesting I believe still you think I
was ported this morning and we are
trying to fight through the timber tea
trees over the bush willows and keeping
our eyes as big and as opened as over an
old just to find we don't miss any bush
because you'd imagine no it's bit warm
if he decides to go flat on the ground I
can tell you we can't see him so we need
a slight movement a slight movement of
him for us to be able to support him and
we have to calm the whole of this area
as long as still take us until maybe
with the same flick hotel or flick and
eav lucky or hitch has to wake up and
say jumbo David this is the area where
he was Leverett telling leopards could
be here and then the next minute they
are gone so no guarantee but cuz this is
where Taylor left him he'll still be
here he would have easily thought of
going to look for food go for a drink
and do not come back to where he was
keep going forward VM
[Music]
and such I tell you we'll continue and
let's find out what's the Bushwick hard
for us thanks Dave well we don't have
anything just yet everybody but well
it's also such a fantastic afternoon
it's a lovely warm warm
autumns day but it's there's a little
bit of a breeze and so it's very
comfortable at the moment and well we
always come up top this chick up from a
termite mound a nice high raised area
just to see if we can see or hear any
animals in the vicinity I think just off
of from where we are here there's a
lovely drainage line that's heading down
towards them low Watty I think that's
definitely worth a little peek down
there and we've got a nice big game path
leading off from this termite mound so
well for me today it's just a bit of a
path of discovery I'm just not playing
and just heading off hopefully find some
predator activity but as I say no real
plan per se for animals I know that
Tandy pralamba has been hanging around
here
Casey you can follow a river upstream if
you are lost but what you want to do is
I would I would probably more more so go
downstream but that's just much is
carefully David he's fallen in a bit of
a odd Foxboro I think and so I would
rather go downstream because for me the
further downstream you go with the river
the more water you're gonna have and
possibly the more people might be around
that water course so I would go
downstream and if you are looking for
water you're always going to be looking
in the pinned digging in the areas down
there let's bend water normally collects
near to the rocks now head down into
that drainage system and then just tick
around and 50s any lipids hanging around
in those trees and we'll just take it
nice and slowly if there are predators
down there because of the the heat that
we've had at the moment I'm just
grabbing some wild basil here always
good to make their hands smell nice
lovely and so because of the heat they
might be resting up in the shade and so
we just need to keep on looking in front
of us and look for any heads they just
pop up but he is flicking and as we come
towards them so we always just listening
ahead and the animals if we do get to
cuss will always warn us with a bit of a
a warming Sun whether it's a growl or if
we hear elephants breaking some branches
at least we can pick it up alien implant
our our approach or not but we want to
try and pick up the animals if they are
in here and nice and early so that we
can make the decisions before we get
there and before there's a critical
situation that we need to just react you
know we want to be proactive we just
walk through the bush nice and slowly
nice and carefully listening as we go
sometimes just stop and listen
it's just the starlings cooling at the
moment nice and cool one of those hot
afternoons now dad monkey yes well you
could be avoiding predators and about
you know I've spent so many years Archer
in the bush that you know for me it's
really interesting to find predators on
the foot in a natural environment we
don't want to disturb them that's not
the idea the idea is just to view them
in the neighborhood natural habitat
especially if they don't even realize
that we're here and let me exit without
them even nine lovely nice shaded area
coming up just in front yeah so we're
gonna skirt around art monkey we're not
gonna just go charging in it you know
I'm trying to find where these pedestals
are we just take it nice and slowly and
just want to see if there's anything
around that we can you know enjoy in a
natural environment and then what more
could you ask from being in the bush
then experience wild animals especially
predators on foot you know we can also
experience bigger animals like elephants
and so on and it's all very exciting so
speaking of those big animals it seems
like James has found you an animal
digging in one of the dung this is a
particularly well difficult done digging
session at this time of the year instead
but as we go towards the winter and
things are dry less and less room to
look for and eat in there
I must confess what a way to make a
living
come let's get the new done pile on a
moveable road and see if we can find a
couple of beetles in it I think he
rejected whatever he picked up there so
there could be dung beetle larvae and
eggs and all that sort of thing in this
kind of done also termites in slightly
older done might find a few oh he's
definitely finding something in amongst
there but you can see why now when we
drive it on the road and suddenly find
these piles that turn no longer
constituted as balls this is why me four
or five balls of this particular
offering have now been chopped up I
think we have a comment from somebody
called post Fridays at Wright post
Friday loving the birding saying so cool
toast cider not post Friday then toast
cider o coast right right close to cider
co-starter not toast cider cursed cider
yes I'm sorry about that curse cider no
I'm getting it in a year from Luke
slight hint of sarcasm you know and I
get here they're all but nervous of the
presenters no thanks in about four days
starts hitting us with a whole lot of
sass am I supposed to be deserved
well scenic I think like I was saying I
think what he's looking for his grubs
and beetles and possibly even fly larvae
that are in the dung but he's going to
struggle at this time of year to find
anything like that there he also I mean
they're omnivorous so they will eat
things like quarry berries so if he
finds a half digested wari berry he
might try and eat that anywhere now he's
fastidiously cleaning off his beak on
account of the will probably foul
aftertaste of whatever is eaten after
the elephants done I'll just confirm
with you just to show you how um
neveress they are I'll read you a list
of all of the things that that have been
recorded eating it's probably sort of
two things but I'm pretty sure that it's
it's a it's a large large amount of
stuff right most food items taken from
ground many by digging with Bill in
loose soil detritus or herbivore
droppings will we've seen that hungry
yeah 35 percent and 65 percent of wet
and dry season food items respectively
in herbivore dropping so I'm talking I'm
talking nonsense they're saying here
that in herbivore droppings they are
more likely to find their food in the
dry season I suspect that's because
there's so few insects anywhere else
anyway they will prey on foot on all
Hawk insects largely insects beetles
ants termites flies eggs larvae are the
larger arthropods grasshopper centipedes
Tim on satellite school sometimes even
miss Ling Birds who I've just since
rarely eat small seeds and fruits eg of
the Shepherd's tree so don't eat a lot
of fruits then so definitely not looking
for quarry berries in amongst that done
I think what we should probably do then
is go and look in the done ourselves
what do you say Craig are you excited to
go and rummage around and done
so let me just clarify what that said
that said it's often looks through done
right and it gets 65% of its dry season
forage I mean obviously there's not
every single bird in every single area
but in the Limpopo Province which is
where we are here it gives 65% of its
dry season forage from a dung pile like
this one well you can see what it sees
here cars not moving is it it is all
right so if you want to link a link away
you just tell you just tell Craig so
what we've got we've got we've got ants
lots of ants they're actually lots and
lots of little beetles and things in
here tiny little things what else I'll
try and catch you a beetle let me just
bring you this piece nice is Carl moving
so it is still quite moist is pretty
disgusting the stage of sudden existence
can you see things crawling around in
there Craig as I break it open so just
look focus there there's a BT yeah you
see there black beetle II yes
I'll next my finger you can't see it on
your screen but maybe they can see it
there there lots of things actually
every time I break open a thing a whole
lot of other things crawl inside so this
is not that fresh I mean it's been here
probably a few hours it's cold but it's
still moist so there's lots in there for
that hornbill to eat and I guess the
reason that the dry season forage is
made up so extensively by on below by
elephant dung is that that's often the
only moisture that there is for the
invertebrates to get into very
interesting very interesting
[Music]
exactly
Miffy smell of elephant dung now
pervades around the car
it is delicious when it is of the right
the vintage needs to be about a week old
before it's really Pleasant and that's a
couple of hours old so it's not quite as
pleasant
well well I have been looking at the
ridiculous
david has found the sublime
well James I'm sure you know it's not
only the homebuilders that will feed on
download' particular herbivores even
leopards have known to be scrubbing and
going through dongs of buffaloes or
Ellie's and trying to feed on things we
do not know broadcast they feed on
bitters inside those tanks and finally
finally look who we got there we got the
do Quincy of mr. t and I think he is
enjoying his cabin up has most cuts who
do people have always thought his only
lions that will sleep but even leopards
given the right conditions will also
enjoy some very good enough especially
in the mid of the heat of the day when
the temperatures are high like now quite
allocation and who'd ever know that this
leopard was there having not foreign
information mercy thank you for having
followed me from yesterday and the day
before saying go go go David Lee openly
reporting anything Ghana thank you very
much Massey and I would say yes which
ago I got Ching Ghana the right there
for you please enjoy viewing it and I
would a cool cut he is
I think after all the frustration I had
at trying to get flowers to all the
ladies to organize lady viewers
including my wife and getting you some
flowers for the Mother's Day I think
Tenggara is making up my frustration
like you know David don't worry I know
you tried hard to please all the ladies
through the flowers you didn't get any
I'll be here and I think my appearance
is going to spice up their beautiful and
big day today I just want to thank
Tanana for this bang they're not once
she will leave a cat one place and you
drive a new back truck half an hour
later not trees and the cut will be gone
and more so to the leopards you can see
little irritation there either form
flies or something but I guess he is
just enjoying some nice nap he is facing
us you can see the whiskers and quite
nice location could be a bit cool where
he is
you don't see him punting as we saw him
the other day when you could use to the
panting in the from the neck and even
from the tummy area he is like breathing
very quietly now what age could be
another element
tenkan rock music you're asking by not
panting means he is not hungry
I would say no one yes yes in the sense
that if where he is he good to me what I
can see he got very good [ __ ] where he
is and that's like a good drainage area
and more from the not drainage areas
will carry water when it rains so out to
the ground where he is he's a bit cool
and that's why he's very relaxed they're
not panting he could be hungry also
because and well yeah I mean he could be
another fool when they're full they tend
to pant a lot because what should happen
if it was so much food in it and the
digestion is going on at the same time
so that one also raises the levels of
panting so yes I mean it could be either
but to me that belly looks fine but I
think he chose a great spot to rest the
ground is cool nice shade from the tree
cover the bushes he is under there and
you can see just small respect of him
that's like getting the right Sandra
Swick it's very well shaded and the
movement apart from the ears that you
see flicking here and there he looks
fine very good Christian and you asking
how much would ting gonna weigh ting
Ghana as traveres just from my look how
to say he is anything 60 to 70 kilograms
60 to 70 kilograms I would say almost
150 160 pounds give or take and that's
my estimate he to me he looks a big boy
and massive do not big head I'll give
him an estimate of about 70 kilos or 150
150 560 pounds in weight in general
males tend to weigh the more heavier
than the females
Ashley you'd like to know if the
Leopards here are bigger than the
leprous in Kenya Ashley I would say
incidentally what I've found out they
are practically the same in any form or
in any shape I've been looking at them
the last three weeks they exactly the
same Ashley sighs Oh check color the
pattern of the rosettes exactly the same
behavior how they go for food and the
prime number one food bank in Palace
Ashley I would say the Leopards here and
the lepers in Kenya exactly the same and
also they you know they're the same
species but very good question there
because I'm so I should have been
following me doing parallels and
comparisons of the animals here and the
animals in Kenya the animals you get in
Kenya the animals you don't get there
that are here yes for the leopards same
in everything
we'll just be looking up and waiting to
see if he'll wake up as it cools he
might decide go get some dope nice
speak of the devil he turns a little bit
she ain't gonna get hurt on the other
side all right that was not bad we know
you are there kickin and doing well
that's a good sign and he might decide
to go get some dinner for himself or go
have a drink
or little stretch we are in no rush and
Jasmine who is walking have some a bit
for us everyone I've got lots of things
to show you but I'm down here in a
little drainage line it's heading
towards them well what you were not too
far away from waiting Ghana is and I
just want to show you a couple of things
that grow down here in these river on
top areas next to the water oh well you
know it looks dry here but I guarantee
you this water below the surface one of
these little drainage lines and we often
get these kind of spark thorns down here
lots of them next to the river on the
edges of the riverbeds
and always also tambuti thickets we've
been walking through a whole forest of
timber teas and I was just saying that
if I camp out here in the bush I would
definitely be camping in underneath as
some dumb booties because you normally
have a very clear surface underneath a
the elephant's market because it's also
very clear and so they've often
flattened it nicely as well but look at
this walking through the river on system
here we find all sorts not from not only
fascinating vegetation but also some of
the thicket animals that like walking
through them the bush and niala being
one of them you can generally get quite
close to them on foot and not as
skittish as a lot of the other animals
may be and in fact we've found them
around our bush camps they almost become
time and they can often be in and around
the tents especially when there's lions
in the area they they almost know that
it's safer to be around humans and a
little
Kent then then be out in the bush where
the Lions would he quite easily grabbed
him and we often knew when the when in
Yala were all banded together in little
groups inside the camp we knew that
there were lions around but this one
just happily browsing through there the
bushes there and you can see he's got
those nice white tips on the edge of it
on the end of his horns that does
indicate he's getting to be an older
bull in his prime as they start getting
to that links and that color on the top
you see quite selective that as he feeds
taking off the exact leaves that he
wants so so got quite a black tongue
some of it to the giraffe but obviously
not as long and thick and we had the
pole this morning which one is which
entered up is the most elegant the kudu
one was the Nala coming in second and
the bush back third but I mean when you
look at this in the natural environment
they are very pretty as well hey
scenic I'm going to now actually look
around for some xerophytic plants for
you okay so stick around and I will try
my best to show you it's hardly a breath
of wind there's a little bit of clouds
around at the moment and it's just
wonderful to be done in such a quiet
area my silent the silence is almost
deafening but I think we should move on
a little bit and have a look around the
cornea now cursed sorry yes that little
face marking and they've got all sorts
of glands here on their forehead and
they will be mocking bushes and things
right like the the impalas Hornung
bushes you have the duiker and things
like the type b the hartebeest with the
pre-orbital glands they also want that
hormones on different bushes etc sights
it's all in I love marking a territory
so you wouldn't find per se and non
territorial animals marking and in st.
marking like that it's mostly or you're
territorial animals that you've all the
beasts as well they also mark with their
feet and they'll make big scratch marks
and they also roll in that area defecate
urinate etc and trying to mark the
little patch of the bush so coming up
here
so as I said we're not too far from
where David is within Ghana but we're
gonna loop around now and check out some
of the other areas of this particular
drainage line a little bit further wood
towards the north but while we try and
pick up some tracks and things they
teach you back to David was ting honor
yes
and the Duke ting Ghana T himself still
enjoying the end up there and he just
turned a bit and faced the other side
and turned facing us and huorchi looking
or hoping is that he might have a bit of
more movement than before you can see
the head there so he initially turned
very good job there but walk there
good come along for him he fits the
other side and you can see now we have a
better view than before so he moved his
head his head a little bit out over the
branch that he got on his head and that
sometimes could be an indication maybe
he's getting close to him wanting to
wake up and move and as we're talking
about leopards in Kenya and in South
Africa I think we had a viewer by the
name of Ashley I just was wanted to let
you know we also got different not a
different species of zebra of leopards
in Kenya but if you go to the very high
elevation areas in Kenya on Mount
Canaria and another area that it's
called urban their ranges if you look on
your map you can see central Kenya we
took more elevation of about 7,000
meters above sea level very very high we
got little paws there that are dark in
color you might be stick them for
Jaguars or see Pumas they're dark and
they do not have any spots on them
and you might think the different
subspecies but they're the same leopards
but they tend to be dark in color
because of where they live and the
ductless is just a color
hybrid that you know enhances the
stroking abilities
that woman is so duck it's very
difficult for the prey to support them
but there's just the same species like
the other leopards we see Amara and
where we are and we got something that
the leopard in Ghana might want to eat
sometimes very lucky to get one of these
things this is a bristling Impala and
he's now bristling at the niala behind
him just indicating that he wolf and the
tail is up skunk style indicating that
he is not to be trifled with lightly I
got something about Ella's cactuses and
Ralph's not for what that meant from the
final control and can we have that again
please Luke I'm just gonna reverse
slightly
as quickly going to talk to David while
we look at this David that was all Barry
saying he would like to come in only if
Kangana gets moving so just keep him
posted on whether tingling gets moving
or not alrighty so he's now past the
ambit of the other male niala which
means that he can put his mantle down
his skunk tail back between his legs and
can move swiftly on to find something to
eat
he looks like he's moving stiffly
doesn't he they all look like that until
you see them run it really is quite
astonishing how fast they are all right
here we find ourselves at the at the
Gauri Dam via tell of dam and there's no
water there at all but there is a little
pan but those impalas go to Eden parlors
Nuala's go towards and during the
drought we had some immensely wonderful
action around there we had everything
Buffalo hyper Potamus giraffe ah now a
few of you asking about why his hair was
up on his like that I'm sorry I should
have explained that immediately let's go
little bit version I'll explain
basically Nuala's and most animals out
here will try and avoid physical contact
if they can because obviously or
physical conflict if they can because it
can result in injury and being injured
out here is not great because medical
care is less than well it's probably
better than it is in most of rural South
Africa but it's not very good and so
what they do is they had this display
where they put their Mantle's up and if
you watch this chap he's gonna do it
again when he comes into the ambit of
this other male he's gonna put that
white mantle up on the back of his back
you'll see him it's now erecting it
and then what he'll do is ruffle the
hair out on his tail and stick his tail
up as well and what that does to the
other male is display I'm not sure
exactly what it says it says something
about dominance it says something about
I'm big and ready to fight if you want
to fight and then the other male will
sometimes back off or he'll do the same
thing and then they'll go through this
elaborate kind of dressage pad order or
do do it and I'll walk around each other
for a while and somehow they decide that
one is bigger and stronger than the
other and then they split apart but very
seldom they will be unable to sort their
differences out with this little belit
ik Tai Chi dance and then they will
fight and the fights are quite
spectacular to watch yes project alta
you're absolutely right we could pile
erections exactly the same as these
niala do but for slightly different
reasons so it's the same thing the same
neurological response and muscular
response as goosebumps basically it's
what causes the hair to stand up I think
it's more voluntary though with these
animals and in fact with most animals
that get their backs up if you like to
get the hair up on their backs I don't
think we can do it nearly as voluntary
as they can but that is a very good
point it's quite possible that the
desire for dwarf Mongoose is now about
to be met
well everyone you know I just wanted to
stop here because these look like they
could be harvester ends but I'm not
quite sure exactly what they are doing
we can see that there's a lot of workers
all busy working working what I'm not
quite sure but there's one or two or
three or four soldiers here as well and
it's just a nice spot to be able to
indicate the difference that we could
see between workers and the soldiers
trying to work out what they are
actually up to this seems to be some
kind of pupae that they've brought to
the surface as we can see with that at
the end of my stick there as they all
got to protect it it's probably pupil of
their or theirs
I don't think that they've stolen it
from anybody else but then there's also
for instance a little bit further back
oh no oh yeah lovely soldier
yeah much bigger and in himself and I
don't know what they're doing with these
soldiers I mean every now and then they
just get a vibration or blur a little
bit of air flowing over them and they
all sort of rush around and they
actually make a bit of a noise and it's
like sure and that's quite similar to
the mutter Billy ends which are raiding
ends they still all sorts from different
termite colonies and other ends as well
but these ones making a very similar
noise to them as well now this is the
kind of thing that we do start to see
especially around this time of year now
Paula these are actually very small
little ends if I put my my hand next to
them there we do get smaller red ends
and we're gonna put my hand all the way
on the ground because they might bite me
and I don't want to disturb him but we
do it's smaller little red ends and
these ones are more so like the harvest
and some believe and what I was saying
is that around this time of year and
heading into winter we're gonna start to
see less and less invertebrates and
insects and an activity on the ground
and little nests like this but the ants
keep us entertained right through winter
so we need to start looking at all the
different kinds of ends that we find
around here as well because they're
going to continue everything else is
quiet and dormant or in the egg phase or
whatever so the art fork also start to
eat them more now Ashley I'm going to
exhibit what these little ants
excuse me exhibit a use as a defense
mechanism now one story just to look on
to them and I'm gonna blow just watch
yet you see that okay if you're watching
the nice and closely what's yeah okay
there's a little bit of running down
towards the hall and they're all know
there's a few that are all just sitting
waiting at the at the edge of the nest
and I'm pretty sure that if you tap
there or there was danger the these
soldiers would all come out now I'm
wondering if these soldiers have
actually been injured as a result of
some kind of attack that they have had
and this is the sort of the end of it
that they just checking up on all the
dead and injured and wounded I'm not
quite sure that's why we've happened
upon this and there is all sorts
happening but I wonder if they've been
raided or as they've been off riding you
know you have quite a lot of these
raiding talk parties with ants as well
and then when I ride they they want to
be taking the little pupae and things
that we've been seeing there and that we
bring it back to their nest possibly for
food which is what the matter Billy ants
do maybe there was a raiding party of
matchabelli answered can through here
who knows but it's definitely some some
wounded and injured warriors or soldiers
over there and the workers seem to all
be trying to help out I don't know if
they putting them out of their misery
be chopping their heads off and getting
them finished with the job so that they
might be using them as food you know
let's not past ends to do that everyone
is sacrificed for the greater good of
the colony and well it's almost like
Vikings isn't it and it's incredible
this cost system works it's incredible I
love watching bees ants wasps all of
these sociable gregarious animals with
some of the most intense communication
systems now we're gonna continue on see
what else we can find a David is still
the sting on all right keep your trucks
going you never know watching my tea and
cam treating Ghana he makes some slight
movement there a little stretch and
hopefully he rise and shine and walk
around and I can tell you all this time
my eyes have been glued to this
beautiful card who not want to watch
such a beautiful leopard and as I said
the other day as Tobias I think he's
doing extremely well extremely well many
many levels when they get to that age of
12 years well Taylor might have said he
doesn't have the physique he had before
nothing he's still doing very well and
Robert you'd like to know how many hours
do they sleep for well that's a very
tricky question to answer because
there's so many factors that come in
play is say availability of food to the
condition of the leopard and three a
general behavior of leopard they're
supposed to tend to sleep longer than
others the leopards when they know is a
challenge to get food they'll have to
spend more time making sure they look
for prey and either even if they don't
eat it the cached somewhere and again
they're leopards
you
who knew whether they sleep on or the
moment they decide to go for a kill
Robert they will get all the ones
without you when the conditions right so
it depends say from one lipid robot to
another since the found ting gana here
spends pretty good time you know having
another fast time I met him he was
sleeping and half the time who was
sleeping the same case today minimum I
think the question is to the leopard
sleep on the tree there's the question
look sorry minimu I would want to agree
with you or rather your question is do
they sleep longer who when they get
older
definitely definitely I think yes just
like human beings who you know notice
when we get older we tend to sleep warm
show you might have seen your
grandmother your grandfather please
stand like turning the clock backwards
you know when you're a little kid how
you spend more sleeping less time for
play and again as they age they tend to
sleep more in general cats behave that
way and Lampard's I think no exception
now saying at 12 years going to 13 maybe
max 15 it'll be something commendable if
he is going to hit that figure
chinga know when do you want to wake up
and you must have been there for a very
long time till left with a around nine
o'clock or 9:15 so this is so many hours
of nap
and I should robot is worried for how
long I could not continue sleeping there
and you'd like to know if 10 Ghana is
trying to get his territory back I think
he is still in very good shape and I'll
not be surprised if he tries to
reestablish his territory and like any
other animal as you know age catches up
you still want to show the other animals
all set for this case the leopard here
you still won't show the other males you
are still there alive kicking and you at
your best so minimal there could be a
possibility he might start to encroach
what used to be his surgery very very
quietly but surely I'm sure he may want
to do that but he got a huge territory
from what I gathered King Ghana got a
pretty good territory if anything he is
only concerned maybe would be Haku Mori
who I haven't met and I'm really looking
forward to meet hook Murray typically
parts typical cuts enjoying ups same
case we see in Kenya you know even the
Mara but in the Mara they tend to sleep
more you know in midday or in the heat
of the day like this on top of the trees
unlike on the ground that's rather
strange and then when you go for the
north to the central part of Kenya I was
talking about where you have this black
or what you called melanistic leopards
they tend to remain in thickets in the
grass right on the ground very very
rarely you see them climbing trees
because it's very very cold or such high
elevation of about 15,000 also feet
anything above a big tree like that
embodies or the marula would be very
very cold for the lepers so they won't
keep in the grass and where they
pushes of the classes are much
and that way we'll be able to keep the
body temperatures warm Lucas welcome to
our world and please remember Lucas you
found out maybe how you send us
questions on Twitter hashtag Safari life
Oh can always look up followers on the
YouTube main stream and thank you for
joining us yes I think mail APIs in
general yes stronger than the femurs and
in animal kingdom males be they leopards
lions elephants Buffalo's they tend to
be stronger than famous and I think ting
Ghana is a classic example
and also the Buddha size is a big if you
look at them carefully you'll notice for
example in Ghana this is one of my
favorite leopards Lucas that of country
level they are the many leopards have
seen here in South Africa he got quite a
big head and you can tell you know he's
a male and strong good-looking boy and
come to leopards think of them again is
notice just below their necks Lucas they
got some developed some big muscle
hanging just under their necks and the
females may not have that and most
females could be anything 35 45
kilograms so look at that all the males
some of them may be liked in Ghana might
be double that weight
I hope Lucas you agree with me when you
think of animals and make sure you keep
following us Lucas and sending us more
questions and that way we'll be able to
educate you and you engage us just love
this boy and my friend James has
something sometimes the leopards put on
the menu list I don't think I've ever
seen a leopard eating a Gyptian goose
but I suppose yes there probably might
he's an Egyptian goose yes seriously
desperate all seven still there the
parents here determined to make me eat
my words about their skills it also
seems to be I mean this is not unusual
for me and I don't even do it
intentionally but I've managed to cause
some offense by saying that I didn't
think they were very good parents and
I'm being berated from various and
various angles on social media and I do
apologize for causing any offence there
obviously you know doing their best I
accused them not of any intentional
neglect of their previous clutches it's
just quite fun to projectile
anthropomorphic perspectives on to these
animals sometimes everything is fine and
dandy here on Sunday afternoon
hippopotamus continue to do nothing of
any great entertainment here and I
believe all of you who are taking an
interest in the lives of these Gosling's
giving a thoroughly enthusiastic thumbs
up the day around
I think that they are now going to have
to become a major part of our safari
lives show because they really are a
regular character always around and
mercifully unliked in ghana one of our
other regular characters they actually
do something and see they're drinking
and eating first in ghana was very
active this morning so he's a little bit
tired
he's a cat after all these fellows are
on the forage all the time for algae
seeds it's a fresh grass now I do know
of course and this is for David Guiteau
that they do not taste good and they
don't taste good well there are two
stories about this firstly I know that
they are not very favoured in most parts
of South Africa because they occur on
golf courses everywhere you go now
South Africa is a place of rampant
unemployment and there are a lot of
people who are not going to look askance
at eating a wild bird if it's available
and there's certainly lots of them
available all over the place
they're very widely distributed even in
cities and yet they remain uneaten which
tells me that there must be a fairly
unpleasant taste to them the other thing
though is to say that my father has a
friend who's all my parents have
neighbours and the lady of the house
this is no no she knows how to cook it
nicely you can take the you can mince
the breast of an Egyptian goose and you
can make a toast quite nice so I did say
well is that not because you know with
mince basically tastes are tests like
whatever you put in it and she did sort
of agree that that was probably the case
and I'm sure ting Ghana would agree with
me it's probably why he doesn't eat them
very much pulses he gets older
they may become more and more part of
his diet
hopefully not these seven there we need
to name them after seven famous siblings
our team we are going to look and see if
I can find some individual markings on
these juices perhaps two for naming
purposes in the meanwhile Ralph is
looking at pool looking at an entire
ecosystem and all sorts it's going on
inside this elephant pirata because look
at that there's a whole termite colony
that has made itself home inside the poo
of an elephant ball and well after that
it looks like the ents have invaded and
they're taking lots of little termites
away with him there's a whole war going
on here it seems a big battle between
the termites and the ends now these
termites as you can see if Davi can cut
in on some of these ends that are busy
carrying
termites away these are obviously
carnivorous ants that have attacked this
mound but these little termites white as
they are they don't have any pigment in
their skin so they're not able to
actually do the work that they need to
in the midday Sun so when the sun's art
they would literally get sunburned this
one there and so what they do is they go
on the inside of things or they cover it
with some of the soil and saliva and
then they work on the inside but in this
case they've literally just come up from
underneath I would say and then been
working on the inside and they've been
working away at all of these grass
clippings and it seems the elephant is
made they laugh easy because normally
they'd have to go out and carry that
back into their nest well they've been
enjoying just the fruits of the elephant
having collected all for them and
the ants have invaded and are carrying
away a lot of the termites carnivorous
ants obviously going to be going and
eating that back in their own burrow so
all sorts happening hey and wonderful to
see how just one elephant dung ball can
make such an ecosystem with the termites
first of all degrading that turning that
grass back into some similar bill energy
and now the term the the ants having
attacked them you know it's almost
completing a whole little cycle from the
grass coming up through the soil the
elephant's feeding on that the termites
feeding on the dung that the elephants
have dropped and now that the ants
feeding on the termites which have been
made available as food for them it's
absolutely insane the entire little
system and cycle that is unfolding right
in front of us and wonderful to see the
little intricate system of of tunnels
that the termites have within one simple
dung ball of elephant it is fascinating
so that's what I'm saying we need to
look a little bit closer in winter to
find especially ants and termites doing
all sorts of incredible little many
sagas that are going on here in the bush
and and it's not always about they're
the big stuff Carol and I agree with the
absolutely relentless these ants are
just going for it and everywhere it's
all for one and one for all they will
sacrifice themselves for the bigger good
of the colony and it is just fascinating
I'm sure that these termites have also
activated all the soldier to mats as
well but it seems the ants of sometimes
you know they do take them by surprise
and by the time the soldiers of the of
the of the termites have been activated
it's a little bit too late well from the
Predators of the tiny minuscule world
and the happenings of inside a dung bowl
of elephant let's head you back to David
was ting gone
yes the tongue Buster's betos the tongue
you'll get also being eaten by lip for
the times and our Duke is still having
the best of his time just sleeping not
bothered by us and bothered by what's
happening on the outside world and the
last four days when we saw him as a kid
he had two different kills he had two
impalas at about 300 meters apart that
caught me by surprise because I don't
think I have ever seen a stretch or a
scenario where a leopard will have two
kids and we had similar theories when we
went back to camp anywhere debating
ostrich
that's the best you can do for us okay
we'll wait look at that eye there we're
here can you see me T gonna don't cuz
you I open it up open your body and your
eyes well maybe not now and we still had
a bit of a debate did ting gonna make
the two kills or did he snatch one kill
maybe from another Lepidus for example
we're just thinking we're not very sure
but while in Kenya I have seen leopards
going for very very big prey and I'm
talking about baby zebras baby you know
wildebeest or baby Buffalo's but the
largest prey I've ever seen
leopard bring up a tree is an antelope
code topi and we do not have trapeze
here in South Africa and it was
definitely male and females I highly
doubt they'll be able to bring anything
bigger than they're in size it was
definitely a male huge male slightly
bigger than Tinga now sale and it
brought down a top-end tapas
I like double the weight of leopards
you'd imagine that but the most
interesting thing is how it's a drugged
vastra P up associate tree
such as trees got very thick trunk just
like the jakku berries but thick and
reformed very good basis the angles of
the branches are just like the rola
trees which are very good to patch up
some nice kill I want to show you a
photograph of how a copy looks like and
we'll compare it to it is cousins here
in South Africa what we call the sesame
and Liam very kind of you
nut is our topi back in Kenya and the
top is about a hundred and forty kilos
so we're talking almost 300 pounds of
weight you would imagine it almost 300
pounds and the fully grown male loved
layer part with about 150 choice the
weight it was one leopard I think it was
very bold very versatile and it was
known to bring kills much bigger than it
and that was something I still want to
see what is the largest prey king Ghana
or Komori will bring bring down during
my stay yeah and funny how they even go
for small animals Nancy how are you
today and your Christian is king Ghana
is so hidden and how did we spot it well
we had a small look clue from Taylor was
out this morning so we used
oh we benefited from her sighting but
then we kept crossing fingers Nancy that
will get him Hoya she left him and
luckily yes we found him there and I'm
not sure the unknowns you got me earlier
I was saying I was a bit frustrated when
I was trying to look for flowers all
over the bush here to give to all the
ladies on the Mother's Day and I did not
get any and I ended up getting a stick
and digging the ground to see what I
could get any flowers growing and I
don't think that has ever happened but I
was saying later on that you know this
duked in ghana made up my frustration
of not getting the flowers and there he
is very very difficult for anybody to
have would have seen him there Nancy if
you just even doing a bush walk it would
be practically impossible to see that
boy having a sinuous there and talking
of choices of food
Kangana would like or want to go for
James got some looked at naturally just
stepped behind this vast greens laundry
let's just move carefully
now most people find the winter
landscape here if they haven't seen it
before to be very harsh and it's at the
stage of the year that it starts to turn
this golden brown color and I love the
way the light catches it at this time of
the day and I love the way that the
colors of the camouflage they don't pop
out but they blend in now and this is
why animals at the colors they are at
this time of the year quite often
especially when we look at the mail in
against the green background
he is really pretty easy to see but
against this kind of much grayer
background especially as we get deeper
into the dry season and we start to see
the brilliance of the colors it's now
that camouflage becomes so much more
important than hiding
reven de I suppose it could be you know
the null of dance doesn't is not
accompanied by a lot of males doing it
together at the same time and I think
that's more what rutting would be I'm
not actually sure biologically if
rutting is defined as a whole group of
males having fights together and I think
that's what it is
so I wouldn't just I suppose you might
describe it as a rut but I think rut is
a kind of really collective thing that
all the males in a species do so I'm not
sure that I would describe dancing that
niala to as a rut it's the male behind
us we're not going to look at him
because he'll just see a whole lot of
aerial so we're going to head down
towards Chitwood em and I believe that
in Ghana has decided it's time to get
his Sunday dinner well look at the Duke
T now he is on the move we have been
very very patient here the last one hour
so and it's time also for us to be on
the move let's find out where he's up to
what she wants deal and via make sure
you keep your eyes on him I'm trying to
keep my eyes on the broken tree see I
don't want to find out where okay you
can see him Riley are you coming you
coming you coming yeah and I tell you
what they started to do once they rise
up their first touch scent marking and
you might be getting some smell of
popcorns
the urine muck but I think he just
either laid down there so let's just go
round and find out if maybe he's just
change changing is bad
this is big fun for me Paula you asking
if lapis will ever share their territory
that's very very difficult I mean the
lipids are very solitary cast to start
with and let me just back up a little
bit
tell me vm no that's good foot pull up
yucca trees would let us share the
territory it's very difficult for help
us to share their territories what would
happen is lepers I'm sure you know a
very solitary cut and very very
territorial and once the Cubs are fully
grown see at the age of 18 months or so
they are wind by their mothers and they
are always off to go occasionally it has
been found out occasionally you'll get
the Cubs coming back to their mothers to
share a Kia but that's very very unusual
in general once the wind and they are
fully grown they go their way
two males have not been known or
recorded to share territory and even a
thin they overlap we have seen some huge
conflicts between leopards and moreso
males than females
Kathy I couldn't agree with you more
that in Ghana has a huge neck and yes
that part of that kind of muscle hanging
under his neck Kathy that's what you
call a Dilip and those kind of juleps
you only see them you know on the males
and not the females look at him can see
how big that boy is so here in the
chromic there start sense marking as
he's rising now to shine for us all
right let's just wants to go
and I'm sure the Bushwick boys a trying
maybe also to support a leopard on foot
as we follow this Duke Tigana
well we are looking at for lipids coming
up on top of each termite mound that we
can find but having said that I couldn't
stop I couldn't not stop at this
beautiful tambuti that we found here it
is the largest based tambuti that I have
ever seen it's almost like there's five
trees coming out of one year and it's um
it begs the question what came first the
termite mound or the tree now because we
often ask this and it's it's quite a
difficult question because what came
first the chicken or the egg but in this
particular situation I'm pretty sure
that the tree came first
why because normally if there's a
termite mound and trees that grow or
once the termite mound has already
started is usually as a result of birds
or mammals coming to perched on top of
the termite mound and they're normally
defecating or dropping the seeds in that
particular area like what would happen
if a monkey or baboon came and sat on
top yeah mouth full of marilla's or
whatever you might have and then he
drops that out or defecates on the site
and then it grows out of the termite
mound but within the case of the tambuti
the the fruit and the leaves and
everything about it is slightly toxic so
not many animals feed on it especially
monkeys baboons and animals that you
would think would be carrying the seeds
around are not part of this process so I
believe that this tambuti especially
where we are as well next to this river
on drainage lime that this tree started
and then afterwards the termites that
came and started the amount and how
they'll do that is after the rains you
have those a lights that come out it's
basically primarily reproductives king
new kings and queens and they leave the
nest with some of the spores from the
mushroom from the original nest that
they were in and then they'll fly off
and when they land a different primarily
productive from different colonies would
now land they've got a nice mix of
spores and they've also got two genetic
variations or mix mix
is that they can have from different
colonies and they will just drop the
wings and now normally move to where
these a bit of a stop like a corner or
but what do you have is some things that
are gonna stop them in the bush and I
said termite mound would have been a
nice area that they are sorry a tree
where they would have come and stopped
next to it and then in that particular
area where the rain has been coming down
the trunk it's made it nice and soft at
the base and that's where they'll then
start digging and make the termite mound
and I think the tree as a result has
started to grow in a particular way
because of the termite mound now ivy and
I think that this this lovely tambuti
along with the termite mound it could be
a couple of hundred years old so it is
once again fascinating to be in the
presence of a tree that could tell such
stories and not only the tree but also
down on to the termite not now this tree
is quite some quite specific and then
you need to be quite careful if you had
to use the wood from this tree and
because it is quite toxic it's got a
white latex that comes through in any
little leaf that you pick okay and
that's a multi latex that is toxic it's
not going to kill you but it is going to
turn your stomach out quite badly and if
I would just move a little bit away here
what the problem is is that this time
Bertie wood has now come from this tree
it's it's a lovely heavy wood it's um
would make for wonderful firewood but if
you had to put that on your fire and you
put lots of it on and you cook your meat
over this wood which would make a lovely
fire I must say I'll probably burn quite
slowly but it will have a particular
smell to the smoke almost plasticy and
that would make our meat terribly toxic
because it concentrates that toxin
through the smoke onto the meat so an
honor a few people that have cooked meat
on tambuti and they had very bad runs
for the next few days and they were man
down now I wonder
speaking about men down if King Garner
has gotten up and maybe he's moving
well guess what we got the Duke now up
about and trying to show why he is one
of the best leverage we got around here
and it's just work Astraeus was a bit
just to make sure we give him away a
ship you know and it was got the right
of way and this is one layer but I would
really want to enjoy seeing exactly his
behavior and learning one or two things
about him and one thing I've liked his
walking steady as he is very majestic
Kathy still watching like oh dear
viewers and he's coming and stopping
occasionally and what I'm think is
trying to do they're either trying to
smell either urine mark yes
are you sure very typical of leopards
and most males did you hear that did you
hear that I hopefully did hear that that
was fantastic
and it was a combination of urine scent
marking and of course the suing
something I'm not as hot for a long long
time
that was good too gonna thank you very
much
I've got a [ __ ] of root here I don't
know what Rudy is going to take but she
left fast I mean I haven't had a leopard
so for a long time a long time so what
he did the hearing mocked that
particular area that bacon and then he
was like eating Ghana is your time I
have to keep my mouth shut you can see
the urine spray I'm sure you can see it
on your screen back up exactly what
should is taking here but we'll find out
where he goes and just look at that
magnificent Duke with that golden light
coming through the grass see the dude up
there and who will not want toward such
a beautiful cut just walking by a rhino
Jong they're not bothered didn't look
for anything occasion I've seen them
going through Ellie's dunks and finding
out beetles and eating them so very very
slowly surely ting Ghana we are going to
follow you and find out what you are up
to and at the same time I might sneak on
your trucks as you walk just to be a
hundred percent sure how the tracking is
done a leopard see I've just seen you
fresh and light so let's see where you
are what your plans are where you want
to go
and he might be looking for some food
because the last time we saw him it was
four years ago
and he hasn't done another kill who
knows maybe this could be the day we
don't get so close to him wouldn't want
to invade his space he's turning left he
saw some guinea fowl fly to the left and
I was like too far I'm not sure I'm
thinking of getting you tonight
maybe someone else stopped maybe uremic
again
scrub the ground as usual I'm in charge
here
urine spray a bit of dust blowing up
from his work VM did you see that good
work good job there is or buttered
popcorn in the air now Shrek you say
this is magnificent I agree with you
it's magnificent and I would say like my
friend Sebastian and say this is money
faker it is magnificent and I also like
to say this is money fake
[Music]
we are following you very slowly quietly
Chandana keeping your peace no rush
you in charge here I'm sure it was a cat
he was trying to say he is trying to
re-establish his territory so you're
saying the scent marking could be going
on because the female around and
Shenouda was not very far from where we
are and you have seen before his scent
marks his father smelling the leaves or
the bushes and that is an education see
what he is doing he first smells and
most likely he is trying to find out
which female could have been around here
and she do Lu was here just two days ago
we saw the prints but we never you know
the trucks we never so she do Lu herself
but most likely that is what he is doing
and who knows they might pair up at one
point and it could be the time you know
to go and have no flirting and make
babies I mean just wonderful just having
your own time the leopard walking not
hers by anybody
and still continue to convince me it
will be my favorite liquid so far
look at him their masseur is trained to
bring that Bush down Brazil sure smell
it you can see the university the
splashes prayer I do not know how much
he urine the blood ass of this cuts hold
I would really want to research on that
because I mean in this pray the amount
of liters they keep spraying when they
sent mark their territories I think is a
lot of urine and James is by the
waterhole Rotti I'm at the waterhole
indeed and we have got a fish eagle that
is on the hunt well he was on the hunt
he's been flying around and then he sits
down again and then he jumps up and
looks like he's looking for something to
eat and quite interesting ly what he
does is he uses the wind so he flies
with the wind around to the top of the
bank here where I'm standing and then he
turns into the wind or kind of tacks
into the wind so the wind's coming
basically from the direction that he is
and what he does is he then flies from
here straight across it and what that
does I think is give him a little bit of
extra lift as he's coming in because he
wants a little bit of extra lift coming
in if he's gonna grab a fish will
something like that and get it out of
the water he doesn't want the wind
behind him because it will actually
drive him into the water and he'll be
unable to get up if he catches something
isn't that interesting I think it's
quite interesting I hope you think it's
interesting anyway that's what's going
on here we were hoping to find some
other kind of animal here perhaps a
leopard or lion or tiger but we haven't
found any of those things
you know I'm told there are some
elephants around so we're gonna have a
look and see if we can find them now to
learn you are just five years old and
you said did I wish all the mummy
animals a happy Mother's Day I did you
know I'm not very good with Mother's Day
tool and I hope that you're better than
me at Mother's Day I said happy Mother's
Day this morning to all the bushes
mothers and again this afternoon and
I've been driving past secretly going
every time I see your mother so yes I
have been doing that we can look at some
mothers there I think you'll find there
are lots of hippopotamus mothers darling
the water there there they are
some of them are mothers some of them
are youngsters I think you'll find that
there very few fathers in that
particular group the fathers will be
away it sort of grumbling to each other
about all of the tough things that they
have to do in fact I'd have to go to
work tomorrow dress in their suits
overalls depending on whether they're
white collar or blue collar workers but
the kids are all with their mums there
next to that tree and they're all having
a good time oh there's also the daughter
I've just seen him yeah spotted great
it's the most lovely Sunday afternoon
this really has got a beautiful Sunday
afternoon feeling and I think that the
atmosphere surrounding this cat is
probably very different
and ting Ghana steel on the move and as
usual
join stopping smelling the leaves of any
other leopard before but as usual fast
scratching the ground and then doing the
urine spray and I would some big
homework
tonight's to do and find out how much
bladder or how much urine or the liquid
do the bladders of this cat's hold this
one is time to smell if there could have
been a bit of scent marking before you
see that and it's ethically the same
roads that she do took a day or two ago
walking up that way but now he wants to
make sure well she shouldn't come around
again he is living some trucks to know
what direction maybe he is going or how
they can link up later on would go
closer together
wait are you asking what rude
he's trying on now and this road here it
is called elephant caucus Road is the
elephant caucus road and that's the name
of this road and that's where he is I
just learned that from VM that's the
name of this road elephant caucus Road
and I hope you saw that elephant caucus
that was killed by another male le the
other month and there he is again what a
majestic leopard he is he doesn't look
very hungry to me they look at him
carefully his hindquarters looks to be
in very good shape wants some of the
cards and more so leopards and lions
start edging up you'll see the
hindquarters the first parts of the
bodies to collapse and you could easily
see their bones and especially the hip
bones showing out there but this one if
you look at it carefully history looks
to be in very good shape
and then cats and leopards again mostly
oh but you'll see the ears will be torn
and the retarder because more so males
are involved in a few conflicts with
other males fighting over territory
fighting over females for breeding
rights and so many scars on their faces
hopefully think I will be able to stop
at one point and have a better visual
look on his face and I'll be Aboriginal
whether I can count the number of scars
he got any he doesn't have as many scars
it will mean to me he has been winning
tell me are you asking how big are the
paws of the leopard that would be
difficult but just look at my hand
I would say a given tip that size there
that could be like the size overly open
pole what he'll do at one point with a
good light I will stop and I'm going to
take you down there with the camera to
show you how big they are
but could be hop says you know how the
size of your out say hon they're quite
majestic
there he goes and Ashley you're asking
at what age is Amelia bud fully grown
I mean they are weaned at about three or
four months by their mothers and I would
say they are fully grown and they're
more independent I would say males two
and a half to three years and females
about three years so two and a half to
three years I fee I would say leopards
are fully grown and ready to go and live
their lives
and we'll continue following our dick
ting Ghana
the bushwalk got something interesting
to tell us all Shores well look at this
everyone this is what the beauty of
walking around on foot it enables you to
be able to scratch around in the dirt
and I'd saw something white in the
gravel and I just dug around it and look
what I underst it seems like this would
be a little Steinbach skull and it is
quite impressive I'm not sure if we've
got one in the tent but lovely to see
this is obviously the top part of the
skull at the back of the day you can see
the the sort of brain case holding the
very vital organ in there but the horns
sticking up in the top and as I rotate
it you can see the eye socket would be
and and then obviously on the other side
as well and at the back as I go around
slowly you can see where the spinal cord
would enter in at the brain site there
so and known as to why this little
creature died but as is typical of a lot
of these animals you can see that the
snart sort of chewed off I would say
either Jekyll or hina they generally do
they do that and Lara I agree 100% with
you very cool thanks for your comment it
is nasty scratch around and find all
these kinds of little things all over
the place and it does make for
interesting times our tear in the bush
now we just continuing up here through
this little tambuti forest and let's and
starting to go down quite nicely now
Aidan this little bone is from a small
little antelope called a Steinbach and
you see the small little horns that he's
got my hand mixed it tiny little horns
that they do have and this is probably
even an adult so they are very very
small little antelope that do run around
here and we do get smaller antelope in
South Africa but Sternbach probably the
smallest of this particular area further
down along
east coast of South Africa we have the
blue duiker which is quite a lot smaller
than even that which makes for a tiny
little interact is probably about that
big and almost half the size or the
stanbow which is absolutely stunning
when you do get to see them but they're
very secretive and nocturnal and you
only see them moving around it not also
in pairs like the steelbook
but a more the nature of like a daycare
and that kind of color as well but much
smaller much smaller now once again up
the top of a termite mound here looking
out and just to see if we can spot any
lipids may be doing the same as us
looking and listening for any alarm
calls as we watch the Sun disappear
behind some of the clouds there and
heading down towards the horizon and
what a beautiful setting it is but
speaking of beautiful settings we're
gonna head off and I think James is most
likely also in a beautiful setting of
his own well it is a very beautiful
setting of our own we can see the Sun is
now sterling starting to sink which is
surprising given the lateness of the day
but there's a real kind of try season
fuel to this today there's a cynical
lapwings you can hear and you can see
there's a lot of dust in the air you see
the dust Craig that's why we're getting
colors even at this time of the day and
then there are two impalas who have
given up on the ruts they've decided
that it's time to be friends with each
other again that fighting over ladies is
getting them nowhere and so they've
decided that they will peaceably feed
together and watch out for predators
that might try and devour them during
the course of the night we are on chat
watched wiser
you obviously have seen and there is no
sign of any of the other leopards that
we know and love Paula thank you for
that profound piece of wisdom that
you've shared you say the Sun looks like
an egg
well all I can say Porter is that
wherever you happen to be in the world I
wish I had eggs that were the same as
yours an egg-shaped Sun of course the
interesting discussion point there and
the resection interesting discussion
point there is that eggs come in all
shapes don't they
Paula Paula don't you dare be sorry for
any comment that you make it's wonderful
to have any comments that you make what
you meant was that it's the color of an
egg yes again if we don't have eggs over
here there are more sort of blandish
beige color rather than that glorious
gold so I'm you obviously got some very
special chickens will you live Paula now
egg shapes are quite interesting while
we drive along here some eggs are round
and I'm just trying to remember which
ones I think it's the ground nesting
birds that have got round eggs because
why do they have round eggs it's got to
do with where they're moving how they
roll and you'll find birds that make up
nests have got the oval shaped eggs and
they're placed in such a way that they
can't roll out something like that I've
forgotten naturally what I was going say
about all of this butter yes eggs do
have different shapes for very good
reasons in case you're wondering what
that is the guests at Chitra this
evening are going to be treated to I
suspect a delicious dinner under the
stars magnificent place it will be to be
later this evening
if you've ever been to the bush you will
know that these bush dinners that they
have just spectacular I remember driving
into them with my guests and you'd
always try and make it a big surprise
you see and so what I used to do is make
my guests close their eyes so that they
couldn't see where we were going I'm
sure many of them cheated but others
didn't and what you do is you drive into
this we had a place up at Angola in
amongst the Mopani trees and they would
hang hundreds of lanterns in these trees
and so it looked like a whole lot of
fairies basically were roosting around
where we were having dinner and would be
driving through the dark I'd cut the
lights and say close what's there close
your eyes and then we'd turn the
spotlight off and keep them totally
closed eyes closed pull up outside the
bush for dinner and then you know turn
all the car lights off and say okay open
your eyes and there would just be this
explosion it looked like thousands of
fairies sitting in the trees all around
and the gasps of admiration and joy were
always very satisfying of course they
were then handed a delicious cocktail
like a hostess or host and that made the
evening even better wonderful way to
wire away in Africa night under the
stars sound of hyenas whooping hopefully
in the distance not too close by
sorry I missed that lid project alpha
falling off cliffs points
Oh elephant thank you project alpha you
say the more pointy the eggs stop them
falling off cliffs that's right because
they get orientated in such a way that
they can't roll sideways right in
amongst a large herd of elephants now
very exciting let me just turn off from
creep slowly forward without giving too
much shock and there is a large bottom
break i humble our bottom onto the
winter forage this time it is a
monkeypod tree I will get us into a
slightly better position than this it's
just a we must as first assess what the
herd is doing and feeling where it's
going
I think what I'm going to do actually
pray because it's back up and drive up
that other road because I think they're
all moving that way some very little
ones here which is nice
and we don't have to kind of chase them
from behind
good afternoon how are you delicious
delicious red bush will hmm here we go
just totally ignoring the grass now yes
never too late I agree a very nice
surprise it was to be finding some
elephant especially this is the first
piece of big game I think I've found in
about 48 hours it and to be perfectly
honest somebody told me they were here
so it's not like I found them at all
really here coming the others what
parent is of Mongoose shine in front of
us thank you
who was it it wanted to see it Mongoose
Lara our Laura mujer was it I think you
wanted to see a mongoose well they well
I hope you enjoyed it fantastic sighting
that's from try and find perhaps a few
more as Luke says just giving the
viewers what they want all the time he
is of course being sarcastic but
something interesting is just gone on in
that thicket I suspect a senior member
of the herd said you youngsters get out
of here
no it's that young bull you can see that
he is feeling well shall we say slightly
excited buyings existence and is
obviously chasing the others around
there's a little one sorry Craig
I'm gonna stumpy tailed female doctor
watch it sorry elephant swati's oh well
oh you're just four four years old
watching Safari Lila that's wonderful
well now you say you like to watch
elephant's Heinie's III which means
their bottoms does it
I think elephants have some of the best
bottoms out here and so yes if I was
going to choose to look at the bottom it
will most certainly be an elephant's
bottom will oh and so you and I are in
agreement there that's a funny-looking
bottom will it's only got half tail
looks like a Doberman Pinscher not
really like a polo pony that's very
sweet
that little thing can't be a year old
yet
and constantly astonished a retire my
see an advanced well relatively
intelligent animal like an elephant with
a youngster only a year old very clearly
not independent and unable to look after
itself yet but have compared with a
similarly aged human being infinitely
more advanced physically it really is
quite something how slowly we develop as
infants all right let's move around
gives a slightly nicer view of them
while we do that let's go back to he who
is reestablishing his dukedom Kangana is
trying to wrestle all the trees and the
branches around his area he brings them
down he sniffs them he smashed them
he hurried marks and he just moved a few
meters in front there and we want to
catch up with him he just laying the
ground his name on the ground area right
she's at the moment laying on the ground
there if if we go through here we go
through here we can't catch him on the
other side
[Music]
he's given us some good entertainment
yeah
kiss him there was it too tight okay
William says let's do it the other way
around but if some got some good room
he's enjoying his nap trying to fight
him with a bit of trees just holding
from an edge and I'm sure the elephants
are not giving James a difficult job
like me here
well we're just still sitting here
enjoying our marvelous elephant herd
this looks like possibly the mate shark
although she is sort of in the middle
she's a big cow
she doesn't know very old she's also got
a bit of the leaf stuck in her ear you
see that Craig she's still on to the
green stuff onto the grass but watch
where she's eating it from see how she's
eating it from underneath the shade of
that bush which is where you'll find the
green stuff and of course the Pennekamp
the guinea grass and there she's getting
rid of some of the driest Royer stuff
and trying to get some nutrition out of
the greeny
yes Fiona I would say absolutely during
the winter time elephants need to feed
far more well not far more but
definitely more than they were during
the summer they have to spend a good
deal of time especially in the dead of
the winter breaking off branches and
tree off the bark which is a painstaking
process because obviously there's not a
huge amount of bark on every branch and
so it takes a long time for them to get
sufficient and you can see there she's
eating that grass on a sort of easy
summer's day he'd say January or
December after the rains you know the
amount of nutrition she'll get for the
effort that she's just put in now I
would say probably a sometimes a good 50
to 70 percent bitter maybe even more
than that see now look she's moving the
bush aside
I'm not sure that I'm able to answer
this question sufficiently child of the
University we think elephants avoid
toxic plants we think they avoid plants
that are filled with Tenon's we know of
course that plants will increase the Tet
their tannin levels in response to being
preyed on by elephants and other
herbivores and so I don't necessarily
think that there are any tree species
here that they particularly avoid
perhaps Jim most boria trees I haven't
seen them eating a great deal of Jim
knows pouria or spiked thorn trees I
mean there must be one or two species
that they just don't eat but there will
be individuals in species that they
normally eat that they weren't touched
because the chemical defenses are have
been heightened in response to browsing
eating a bit of zebra wood now they're
moving on to a bit of monkeypod very
selective and not indiscriminate feeders
at all
well tula an aged just five years old I
don't know what happened to that
elephant's tail but lots of things could
have happened
I suspect the most likely thing was that
a up there and then a whole lot of ticks
got into the cut and basically there ate
her tail off which i think is really sad
but she'll be okay and I'm sure was very
sore at the time but it'll be absolutely
fine now so I think you'll find that
something made an injury made a hole in
the skin the ticks got in there and
basically they're the tail off
is very useful as a flyswatter but it's
not impossible for an elephant to stay
alive without one Donna the short trunk
heard I don't remember when the last
time I saw them was it was some time
back I think we have a matriarch now
Craig coming up to the lift here there
is a tuskless cow and I think I
recognize her it's east of one furthest
behind me your shield I'm not gonna move
because she can come out onto the road
in front of us jack is a bit of a
gathering going on there that's a bull
it's a youngish bull they're not that
one that's a young cow with her tiny
little baby no look with this little
thing very sweet craig is that there you
can see through the bush that's a bull
there that guy
no see with his back to you arm that's
him he's causing a little bit of
consternation but he's not big enough to
be a real threat to this lot now I'm
just trying to see the tuskless Carl
there she is she's coming across the
road now I think she's the met Chuck I
think she's older than all the others
and I recognize it well I recognize a
tusk is Carl there must be more than one
in the area
so she's leading up from behind at the
moment that's quite interesting maybe
just shimmying everybody along and I had
started a discussion that I don't
believe that I've had before yesterday
which in three years is quite unusual
that we haven't kind of come across the
topic but the topic basically was on
matriarch of hyenas and maid sharks of
elephant herds and how different their
roles are and how the matriarch of a
hyena clan is much more like a sort of
dictator who lives by force and violence
and takes the best pieces of meat and
lives in luxury in comparison with all
her subjects
it's just rolled out on the hill here
whereas of course in an elephant herd
the matriarch role is a much more
managerial leadership role where she is
not a violent dictator as she is
normally in a hyena clan but much more a
leader and mentor to the rest of the
herd
I'm telling is quite interesting and yet
we used the same term wind is really not
sending very sounding very good well
Ralphie being the friendly person he has
managed to find another friend everyone
we've walked down the drainage line
where that tambuti forest was and we've
come out at twin dams and I believe this
is where Dave had King Ghana in this
area I think of you as possibly in one
of the big jackal berries just off on
the other side but it's always
interesting to come down next to a
waterhole and just check and see what
has been coming down to drink and
besides from what's in the water
I'm sure Davi he was looking at her and
a tear up in a minute ago but there's
been all sorts down here
warthog tracks these hippo checks this
elephant tracks and yards just always
nice to walk in the footsteps of giants
as well putting my little miniature feet
inside where they've been standing here
having a little drink and it's wonderful
and a lot of the banker is actually fold
up with them Egyptian geese checks as
well and just to further the other side
of it there there's a lot of Egyptian
geese down too so it's just interesting
to come down nice and close and see that
and obviously you know the Egyptian
geese have got webbed feet so you see
how they do tyres are sort of curled on
the outer edges and you have this little
triangles forming because of the webbed
pieces in between their tires and lots
of water activity and they've all become
probably coming down having a drink
having a little voila as well in the
water here just on the edge and they are
animals that do like to wallow there's
also water bug checks just up in front
here and once again lots of elephant
tracks they have got inside them and one
or two of the hippo tracks as well as
you see there's some dangly
it's quite interesting lots of seed pups
inside it I wonder what that was maybe a
jackal or potentially even a porcupine
something like that but um luckily we do
know that there's no hippos in here at
the moment because if we met an approach
like this on a small pen like that you
do need to be careful of hippos and also
crocodiles I think this is quite a
shallow pan so if a crocodile had to
grab me here I could probably fight him
off so I wouldn't worry too much
now linen is crystal clear perfection
and lovely reflections especially at
this time of the evening where the Sun
going down in the background there
nights for wonderful light wonderful
photographs as well as the videography
that I'm sure Davi is exhibiting with
these excellent skills so and as I say
as a checker as a guide always just
looking for signs of anything fresh that
is maybe come down for a drink
and unfortunately apart from
gaana it's been seriously quiet and one
of the reasons why I wanted to come to
this area X is a bit of different zones
on foot and see if we could pick up on
any body else besides teen goner
and see if there was fresh tracks I mean
of lions or lipids and but it seems
there's not much of whatsoever so we're
just gonna have to keep on persevering
keep looking for this because we know
how quickly things can change now at
least James is still without big mammals
well yes a little version of the big one
now that may shock is given a signal
they're all moving off I suddenly there
they go there's the big card the back
the big Tusker scars at the back another
big car in the front that means get out
the way so maybe she's it like a backup
I don't know all she's told them from
behind it's time to move on chaps
she's definitely waiting to see what we
do as a result of their disappearance
child of the universe I'm not sure that
I would agree that orcas have a similar
kind of them are similar to elephants
what discover the question again Luke
exactly what other animals are similar
to elephants in terms of social
structure Oh have matriarch similar to
elephants I I know nothing about orcas
child of the universal I don't know but
then they may well have a matriarch that
is similar to elephants interestingly I
mean there are instances in human
society where they've been a matriarchal
figure that has a very similar function
to an elephant where her function is
quite unlike the sort of male dictators
of human history where the senior
members of women's clans and families
their role is largely as a mint
Broll for youngsters and especially
young women so human beings have a
similar I suppose in some cases
matriarchal system I don't know about
orcas but perhaps it's the same with
orcas but otherwise I think it's one of
the very few social societies that are
dominated by not dominated you see it's
not dominated are led by a managed by
the oldest female in the group can't
think of any others aren't here there
are plenty of species where there are
collections of female living females
living with the youngsters but not so
many where there is a actual leadership
role Dhara
I think it's look and smell and feel and
sound and everything else I'm pretty
sure that they can smell their offspring
all elephants look slightly individually
different and so I'm pretty sure that
their parents can probably all their
mothers can see the difference between
their own offspring and other offspring
but I think there is definitely a smell
to it those chunks of sniffing and
smelling all the time but of noise there
a little bit of consternation going on
here a bit of a fight that we move
forward while I answer never to late
this question you find probably never
too late that its genetic that those
missing tusks are a result of some kind
of genetic aberration and she'll
probably produce offspring that don't
have tusks some elephants have the tusks
broken off through use or some kind of
nutritional deficiency that's made them
weak she doesn't have it I don't think
she's got either she's got no tusks
right from the root
so that's unusual as like being born
with two without two front incisors sure
of course when a human being looks
absolutely ridiculous no Ryan we think
so
you know elephants when they get old
they obviously can't move with the herd
nearly as much they can't move from
feeding ground to feeding down as
effectively so they go down to the
rivers where the food is soft and
generally more nutritious and Ryan yes
essentially they do starve to death you
know their teeth eventually wear out and
then that's it and them are unable to
chew anything but at the same time
they've often got old by then and are
showing symptoms of old age which is too
general decrepitude difficulty moving
I don't know how arthritic they get they
don't get the lifestyle diseases that we
get of course but I you know they get
old old age and why it occurs and why we
get old as a fascinating subject when
taking a take away there that's quite
nice
very wise Robert speaking of old age
they can probably get in this area the
textbooks will tell you between I think
it's 60 and 65 years but I suspect in
some areas they're probably live even
longer than that to me that's a long
time since I looked that up I'll see if
I can't find a more scientific answer to
you for you know some actual data
Tesla I think that my favorite thing
about elephants suspicious are sit here
in the evenings the sun's gone down is
well there two things can I give you two
things Tesla your two things one is the
smell especially mixed with the dust in
the dry grass like this
they smell like sweet leather so a
little bit like a new pair of shoes
Tesla but nicer than that and then the
other thing I like about them is that
they make me feel very peaceful when
they're like this they're not angry
they're just feeding quietly and I feel
like that I feel peaceful when they feel
peaceful and so those are the two
favorite things or my two favorite
things about elephants see if we can
have another look here
we don't want to do they've been so
tolerant of us we don't want to sort of
get in amongst them and give them a
fright very gentle as we go just giving
them a little bit of a shove from behind
which isn't very nice so we let them
settle down oops for a bit longer and
you can go and have a look and see what
that cat is doing as the night falls
hopefully the LEDs there will settle
down and our Duke Donna is just taking
it easy much active than before now and
you can see the freaking of the juice
showing more life or more action might
be coming in then alia when we saw him
just flat sleeping this is very typical
of low points most of the day when
they'll be very very inactive and us you
know darkness comes in they tend to be
more mobile and hopefully this is the
time we'll see him trying to do
something I was trying to focus closely
if vmu can go to the ears and you could
see their little tear marks he got on
the es there he's worth saying for 12
years I think he's doing very well he's
always a very good way to h&L a leopard
the team acts like he got on that one
left ear right below at the base there
you can see there's a huge tear there
and could have been a clue or a tooth
from another leopard via to Murray or
something like that I'm not sure what
spooked him there could be another game
drive vehicle coming close but on the
left there you see that he just moved
his a huge I would say water hog oh yeah
I mean a Pokemon just went in there Liam
just to me that's what he looked at
we believe that and their parts have
been known to bring down porcupines I
didn't see it but avium saw a porcupine
going in that burrow there and the time
you have seen what hogs were going in
there but it was a porcupine leopards
have been known to bring them down and
just Deval them who knows that could be
maybe one of the reasons he is where he
is and he came and he stopped there he'd
come from inside an Hotel then when teen
who not cribbing something I got to
another game Drive vehicle that kind of
talk to the never there but if VM tells
me it was a porcupine let's see what
happens and we will find out if the
porcupines might have found someone else
inside that hole there
chances are if the porcupine will come
out all right rise no good you know I
think I know well done what next now do
you good was that's some amount that
have a home for the porcupine is right
there that could be good plans for
dinner what were you thinking chingada
you have porcupine there who else who do
you think you could go for sometimes we
get watch hogs living in there so you
got a choice of say fill it like meat or
you have got a choice of pork chops
tonight I don't know what would smell
better
he's--oh entirely up to you and tell us
what should easily go for I don't think
King Ghana you have not brought someone
on down since the last three four days I
saw you but in between big meals
elpizo be known true gets more birds or
reptiles or steal eggs of birds so
chances are he cannot have been
surviving on the Impala meal we saw him
with the other day and should have
gotten a few little buy things as fuel
snacks to get him to the next main meal
a major costs of maybe another Impala or
another antelope slowly heading up in
the other direction across the drainage
and what we'll do we are going to
reposition herself and quickly follow
him and maybe he is giving the porcupine
a chance maybe to come out of that bow
and the partner think the danger is gone
and I am going to come out painting
Ghana will swing right back let's first
find out where he is god we don't want
to lose him as yet and maybe Ellie's are
giving us a good show at the moment now
there was a baby elephant giving us a
good show unfortunately he decided the
show was over he was lying in the sand
and his friends was kind of throwing
sand on him it was very sweet but then
as he knew you were coming to see him
and got up unfortunately I think it may
be time to leave these chaps
[Music]
and see if we don't find another spot
set of spots emerging from the darkness
yeah it is just the camera NASCAR for
life great name and you say our Sun will
sorry are some elephants too short to
nurse no they're not it does look like
that I even from this angle that I'm
sitting it looks like that it's not just
the camera but they can all reach and I
think sometimes the females must sort of
lean over slightly but I didn't think
that happens very often there's the one
tusked lady all right are we gonna say
goodbye to these elephants have a last
look at them and then you are going to
have the last look at the great Ralph
Kirsten so everybody this you can see
how were these very white thorns on it
is one of the old acacias now it's
called the chillier but I'm pretty sure
that this is a vasilia analodjica or
this sweet thorn it's a it's a little
baby a little seedling it's still got a
long way to go but the reason I wanted
to just show you a little bit on those
thorns there is that we had a question
earlier about zero fatigue plants now
zero fatigue plant is a a plant that can
survive in little to no water conditions
such as in in deserts and that question
coming through from scenic now scenic we
do have some plants that are quite
resistant to drought conditions in these
particular areas and the virtue Lea
being one of them now this as I said was
a virtually analodjica but in Namibia
you get the Virginia Carew or the camel
and it's called the camel thorn because
the camel being in afrikaans the giraffe
is a camel Beth so it's a camel horse
and I just called that tree because the
giraffe feed on it so much they called
it the camel thorn but those are
relatively drought resistant and they've
got massively long tap roots that go
down sometimes up to a hundred meters
and tapping into the underground water
however having said that a zero fatigue
plant does not need to be tapping into
the underground water in such conditions
so plants like your cactuses and your
euphorbias although not these euphorbias
that we get share the candelabra
euphorbia is not zero fatigue plants I
believe it's more so like your desert
you phobias like you once again get in
Namibia the you phobia damiana and there
are a number of different other ones I'm
just I just failing my mind right now
but one plant in particular called the
valve vitya marabella's it is one of the
most amazing xerophytic plants you will
ever see in your life and look that one
up I'll say it again
valve ichiya marabella's it was
discovered by a German botanist in the
Namib Desert while he was the one of the
one of the people to record it and write
about it it was obviously discovered by
the Bushman long before he wrote about
it but anyway that's the reason why he
gets his name in the front of it have a
look at those velvet shell marabella's
plants and you'll see what I'm talking
about as xerophytic plant that can
survive in real dry desert conditions
the plants that we have around in Juma
concession or pretty much low water
condition resistant but they not true
xerophytic plants because then they
would be able to survive in little to no
water whatsoever and we do have a decent
amount of water coming through here in
comparison to the very disciplined ich
ins that we have in the Namib and other
areas right up into the Sahara and all
over the world different desert like
places where you'll have xerophytic
plants surviving in those in
on little to no water it's very very
interesting
Virgilio they are a water less
environment resistant now welwitschia
it's worth the wel t CH i a valve it
jian yes valve Vitya marabella's okay so
look it up if you google it you will see
it is one of the most amazing plants
grows very low to the ground but it is
in fact a tree it is a cone bearing
trees or one of the pine species and one
of the most unique plants anyway in the
world it is only found in a small band
about 50 meter 50 kilometers away from
the coast along the namib coast and
slightly a little bit into Angola girl
look that plant up I'm telling you
you're going to find that something
special unique and totally amazing but
not to say that the acacias or the now
virgilia's are not amazing in their own
right especially with these thorns that
they produce and they do supply a lot of
food to many of our animals around here
especially the giraffe with these little
leaflets being very nutritious and
sometimes more so than even the big
simple leaves that you would find on
perhaps a tree like the jackal berry and
hence the reason why they have such very
short little thorns trying to protect
the very nutritious leaves and their
source of food and survival with those
leaves with a chlorophyll and the
process of photosynthesis so wonderful
wonderful things to talk about with
plants and has been lovely with her with
the are arthropods especially the ents
in this this afternoon and then we also
did have the and we did have all sorts
and that's the wonderful thing about the
small stuff out on foot and look at that
was just got a warthog up front a very
fat water indeed and I can tell you what
he would he would hopefully not fall
prey
file to any of these lipids that are
walking around Saanich in Ghana is not
too far from here and he could quite
easily grab a set piggy like that
and speaking of King Ghana I think we're
gonna hit you back to Dave I hope you
still with him let's what hogs know
there's a potential person here who'd
like them for his dinner tonight
so what hogs once in a while have been
brought down by oops no sure what is it
India by lipids he's leaking maybe poof
something there I'll give em both saying
we have seen them going on leopard on
buffaloes poo and I do not know what
they'll always be eating in the animal
down for like buffaloes and Ellie's a
little get their guests they'll get the
small bit O's but for Buffalo done
tirana you may have to tell me what
exactly you derive what nutrients what
minerals do you get or vitamins you get
from a buffalo meat in there I think
that's exactly what she is doing and not
very easy it's going it's mode you can
tell not like how they eat the meat he's
struggling either to put it in the
throat or down the tummy because of
maybe the amount of grass in it
when he licks his paw
we still trying to get whatever it is
his mouth even if he was something of an
animal kind
yeah because rights Butler done sorry
James
you said this is awesome I also agree
with you to me else a double awesome
double awesome lapras him eatin scrub on
anything of you necessarily getting
proteins or the prey they brain down to
eat but now we have him just going
through some Buffalo dung and I want to
know what the drivers group I mean
Buffalo is a hobby was they eat a lot of
grass
what benefited to be getting to eat or
to gain small bits and pieces from the
buffer land is very trusting right in
the middle of the road there I have seen
us with the monster while trying to eat
Impala poo
reason you asking is the eating it or
shouldn't he threated then he could roll
into it
I still have seen him trying to swallow
part of it in his mouth if you look
carefully there to me he is like he was
spreading it out and either trying to
marinate it making it a little soft
let's wait and see if he is going to
roll all right I have a lot to learn
from you Tenggara hey I haven't seen
this rose in Kenya so I could be getting
one of my big lessons today I've seen
them going to elephant down eating few
beetles and living little they are
getting a few flies if they get any love
you of an insect they'll also eat it but
now for the buffalo town let's see what
he'll tell us please and Amanda's you
think maybe it's like medicine yes who
knows I mean if it has a little tummy
issue or it has some kind of fever
it could be medicine who knows I mean we
have always gone for some herbal
medication locally here in Africa and
buffalos being herbivores they eat lots
of hubs and I'm talking about of course
grass so yeah it could be medicine that
he is gain trying to derive from that
buffalo dangler I'll have to take a very
big lesson tonight maybe I might skip my
dinner and find out what leopards will
be benefiting on Buffalo dung and that
tells me he is eating it either way and
is some benefit of some sort he is
getting it
products you think now I am the official
chingada whisperer thank you very much
giving you a high five for that or let
me give you higher tennyson of high five
and yes I hope I'll remain taganas
Whisperer for the rest of my stay here
in South Africa look at those eyes look
at that look I learnt in Ghana
please tell us what you're doing there
we'll back up and give you wait you in
charge here
you're the Duke and we all know animals
have the right of way you said a
privilege to see them when they give us
such cooperation and allowing us to have
such great views we're not very far away
from the tree what hole and we don't
know they could be going for a drink I'm
just anticipating maybe he's going for a
drink and she was just right there head
of us which is another what 30 meters
from where we are and ting gonna tell us
what would you be wanting to do was to
be up to sir EVM as you show he Yuri max
sent max that area my territory he's
making it much wider looks in the
direction of the waterhole darkness
slowly creeping in change the direction
and is so close smells that bush for any
other leopard that means have done any
scent marking rubs his head on it
Laura you're asking would be eating the
down could help you know fool you know
bacteria for the leopard fortune gun
I'll think it could be the case and they
might used maybe to help them in their
digestion because he elephant I mean our
elephant of Buffalo Dan will have lots
of s'mores more organisms in them so is
the possibility maybe he'll be able to
pick up some bacteria in it that maybe
will help in the digestion of all the
proteins they eat and that maybe you'll
make it Hostin or quickly think of
another kill pretty soon or maybe
tomorrow the day after it's very
possible I agree with you that's a
possibility Rhea so he'll good it smell
if any other leopard had mocked theater
here as issue scratching and then do the
spray of urine yeah he goes yes
Kangana we agree that as a sneeze god
bless you my god did you hear that
were showing Kangana and what a way to
tell me David welcome to South Africa
and might many of you right but was such
a vocalization for me and also hear my
heart James did you hear that James here
we go now we don't have anything like
that this side we are going to do the
southern boundary which is what we're on
now we're back towards Zuma which is on
our right are we all fair was that the
wrong communication okay Lucas is
looking using the wrong buttons on his
radio at the moment and so he will be
either lashed to this evening or given
some strong liquor probably lashing is a
better more effective method anyway we
are heading down the southern boundary
of Juma and we're hoping that the noise
you've just here heard being made by
ting garner might attract the attentions
of oak amore or maybe even shadaloo
feeling amorous so they're gonna go all
the way to the western boundary and
drive up there and see what we can find
that is our plan for the remainder of
the show some twenty five minutes I
think we have lived in the night time
most pleased that we have a little to go
back to whoo speedy darker but then
later sort of puffing noise
unless it just bashed its head into
something yeah I think it just got a
concussion on the bush well
not being chased by anything
no sign of husana
or Tandy or good Chava this afternoon I
was on chitter-chatter obviously
listening I see what most of you think
that it's a very good plan that we give
Luke a lashing good okay we will do that
we will bring out earlier a thin cane
and Lara I believe you are especially
enthusiastic about the possibility of
Luca receiving a good caning this
evening well done good I shall deliver
that now in fact all right I think I'll
get Kirsten to deliver it she is of
course
Luke's immediate hesitate to use the
word superior immediate boss if you like
and so we'll get her to deliver lashing
publicly over dinner and see if that
doesn't help yes as luke says she is
very terrified she might be small but
she is utterly terrified all right we
have a bush baby in a tree up ahead now
we don't it's a light drinking from a
long way away it's not a bush baby don't
worry Craig it is the light twinkling in
bushbuckridge
and as Luke says just prior to his
lashing let's go from a fake bushbaby
to a real leopard while moving from bush
babies to a big leopard here and you
notice now we have gone to infrared
because of the darkness is coming in and
we do not want to shine any bright light
on this beautiful Duke Pingala he has
been very busy he did not stop at the
waterhole as I anticipated
he gave it a Miss and he is working to
what VM tells me used to be a high in a
den so you see how the dynamics have
changed now when we go to infrared which
shows a lot of compassion and making
sure we do not blind these nice cuts
with our light so we'll keep following
him slowly and find out what actually he
won't over he really wants to go in this
darkness it keeps going sent max as
usual goes stop st. marqs sniffs if
maybe there's another
leopa leopard is that might have swung
by there he leaves this mark
we should say eating Buffalo dung helps
with the digestion thank you very much
for that and I guess so
I was not very sure but thank you very
much for confirming that to me and it's
true yes because of the bacteria maybe
that will be in the buffer done many
thanks
so he's still on the move we are still
on the move to forget him VM there very
good so tried maybe swing by on the
right of him and still on the side and
find out what his final destination
would be Jarrell you asking oil does
seem it was sewing noise that you had
and number one that would be of course
territory marking but also he would be
passing some message to would be other
males around and I've just gathered from
James Henry he's maybe biggest concern
now would be hook Murray so I mean there
was a vegetarian soup and most of the
males and that sound or that
vocalization would be a clear message to
Murray whoever he is
don't forget I'm around and all you have
to say and maybe wait and hear whether
Murray will give something back in terms
of vocalization
this fool over to Ghana boy
child of the universe how are you today
I've always liked your name and the
smaller costs like Genesis and C but not
one but I have a hard make that sound of
Labor's maybe they do maybe they do not
I am Not sure and I would be happy to
find out also the found out about the
lipids eating the Buffalo down I have no
idea and haven't had them you know
showing like lipids maybe they do and
they are child of the universe I hope
you enjoying this great view of tin
ghana please don't forget to keep
sending your questions to us or any
comments on twitter a hashtag safari
live or keep following us or the main
mainstream youtube as we continue
enjoying this great view of this big
nice-looking m---eleven
a real Lake is named in Ghana but what I
worry is that in Ghana means being shy I
don't think he's shy all right you've
just gone round coming round
let's go around the other side and see
what he's gonna come out ahead of us
Angelo you asking do all the leopards
have the same pattern no they are
different they are all different you
need to look them very very closely to
see but I would say they all got
different patterns I'm thinking he'll
come out through here Angelo and we're
going to look at his pattern and maybe
when you're lucky one of the days we are
going to look at his sand husana and see
whether there could be anything close to
their body patterns on the results there
which I would highly doubt marking
territory scratching himself mossy or
skin do I think Kangana will be tolerant
or with Santos Anna well what would
happen as age comes hasanah might want
to show his dad also his growing and
coming to age and maybe you want to try
him out full territory for competing for
territory I highly doubt that would
happen I highly doubt and ting gana will
still want to you know show husana I'm
still your father
I'm in charge here please keep away from
this area I highly doubt sweetie Nana
looks very very good and I don't think
you take any in any worries from husana
masa don't you think that leopard is
huge must what do you think give me your
feeling or what do you think would
happen if king Ghana would meet horse
Anna right now what do you think would
happen do you think they'll say hello to
each other do you think asana would say
hi Dada missed you how have you been or
do you think they could go for each
other good teasing and clawing and like
what the hell who do you think you are
Massey said send me your filling it's a
me a comment on Twitter as usual hush
dog Safari live and we'll have something
to compare tonight as we follow this
do you garner in the darkness of you
gonna watch out huh are you good to go
alright VM survived he has survived so
many branches today
well for him let's find out what update
James got for us now
driving aimlessly flapping the spotlight
about ineffectually and trying to find
something of worth I'm up to David yet
again putting me to shame it's difficult
for me to deal with given that he's only
been doing the job about three weeks he
has a course called 20 years experience
under his belt and on account of his
general pleasantness I don't really mind
that much but I really would like to see
a cat at the stage use the infrared
lights to see the cat's follow them on
the hunt I included Saturday last week
with the Oklahoma pride which has since
disappeared unfortunately but how
marvelous to have Tenggara back yelling
his head off and proclaiming that the
Duke is not yet done
there are some Impala up ahead now we
also need to decide between us you and
me and obviously the other presenters
etc if Jen garner is the Duke what are
we going to call Hoch amore I quite like
the fact that there we don't have a king
leopard I don't think that that's would
be for some reason I didn't feel like
that it would be appropriate I'm just
telling the lights of was the getting
past him in Palace and so what if King
Garner is the Duke will just sukumari
going to be the if I count of Jummah the
Earl of the north
perhaps I quite like she do loo being
counted as the Duchess of the north
I'd like that one I'm not sure why I
came up with that I'd like it Tunney is
I think should be the queen I think
that's what her designation should be
local Murray I don't know it's like a
sort of swashbuckling night type the
warrior chief may be the warrior chief
not what do you think everyone warrior
chief Oh Kumari well yes W James maybe
that's a good one okay Murray the
Conqueror it's about nice good nice ring
to it Craig what do you think
yeah we should call him her uncle more
either Gemma you reckon the count count
will Kamui Alec I like that one too
I also like that countable marine
nettles guard battle-scarred count the
night the night of the West the western
night the northern night English
Ethan you want to call him the Black
Adder I I can't help if for those of you
don't know what English talking about
I'm assuming she's talking about Rowan
Atkinson's and character the Black Adder
and if you haven't ever watched Rowan
Atkinson performing in the fall series
of the Black Adder
from somewhere in the late 80s I think
they were they were made they are
hysterically funny and you need to go
and watch them I think that hooker
Murray is slightly more noble bearing
than any of the full Black Adder
characters it is the blackest humour
you'll ever see absolutely
side-splitting stuff
I think it says hookah mori
all righty Kangana has emerged from his
thicket it has stopped all the silliness
and go back to him yeah
Kangana remains top here of the world
and he almost got a what how good that
just came out of that burrow there -
went running and I do not know what
would call Okumura if King gana will be
the Duke and force and with a little
chief well we may have to go back in the
camp and all the guidance will see
together and get a good name for Hawk
moreover in the meantime let's stick
with a Duke for this wonderful King
Ghana boy now he isn't top of a termite
mound there and then nobody is looking
at sorry KC asks how far what
the sewing could do anything like I'd
save 3 3 good kilometers about a mile
and a half yeah my half to 3 key here or
3 kilometers depending you know on the
vocalization how deep it is that would
determine how far it would go out say 3
kilometers or about one point eight
miles that's how far it would go
just find out to be looking for
something to eat and termite mounds are
always good hunting grounds for leopards
it could be porcupines in there to be a
mongoose in there it could be a warthog
in there is he on top berries on top one
minute we just need to look kids I think
it's right on top there what do you
think yeah good job and he might be
waiting there to see what would happen
is right on top of that Hammond mound
and that's a we saw a piggy just coming
out running for its dear life so we have
seen two plus years initially we saw
occupying and now we just saw a picture
that hole there so sorry about that
that's where the water came out from and
a similar like barrel we saw a porcupine
go in and it cannot come out that he
knew there was a lot of danger lacking
by the door I can tell you we have moved
about 2 3 kilometers with sting Ghana
this evening and I have known leopards
which would go comfortably 20 kilometers
in one night you know either searching
for food or changing locations or
territory marking and the snots you know
small this has been standard I mean
talking of about what or 13 14 miles in
one night and that's normally happens
more at night when school
and we'll always have better chances you
know of getting prey James Henry want to
tell us something
yes Here I am still looking around I
believe there's been a few more names
what are they do cos give them to me now
immediately P Hart you reckon the Black
Prince for who Komori friend tsukumo
reacquired like true that he should be
black necessarily I like Prince for
coumarine Marius is Jon Snow Jon Snow
who coumarine think about Jon Snow well
we don't know where he came from you
know it might be he's uncertain ancestry
okay Murray the what the girl the Earl
ppb gb BBC GP PBGC's the elf
I'll hook Murray I quite like the oh yes
I think that the Earl is a good one
because we have a Duke why shouldn't we
have an earl not entirely sure the
difference is
this is Lapwing you are bringing us all
back down to earth and saying how about
just the male leopard who can worry the
male leopard well yes I suppose we could
just call him look Maury the male
leopard yes of course
look amore the male leopard perfectly
reasonable wait I think I spotted a
chameleon now watch how my stock will
plummet when we realize it's a leaf
there's the chameleon is it
that's not Daisy look at that crazy
isn't it amazing it's a leaf or a fruit
incident it's a fruit it's a large fruit
fascinating stuff
good alright I think that David given
his performance soft neutral to have the
honor of saying goodbye to you I will
just meekly and quietly disappear Craig
turn the light off into the night
goodbye
yes sir stuff start disappearing into
the night I think Jim's right Heidi Sam
all the owners to open and maybe close
our Sunset Drive today as you can see up
there the dead tree they I'm guessing
this may be Venice planets in the
background and we got our Ducote in
Ghana right on top of that amendment any
firm teaming just part of the termite
mound that makes him blend in so well
unless you see you move his head like
you see there you could save us a tune
parts of that Taman mound
or what you can hear now a cicadas some
frogs from a distance the busy nocturnal
animals coming in the dan ones are
giving away we have had Ellie's today
lots of antelopes
but I think ting Ghana has won my heart
and hopefully he'll get some dinner
tonight he had a choice of going for
Phillips or going for the pock and I
can't function Ghana enough and this one
viewer who gave me the name the king
Ghana Apsara I am keeping that name I'm
going to change my documentation and
have a new name and to all of you thank
you very much remember to join us
tomorrow morning 6:30 central Africa
time goodbye from all of us
you
[Music]